Hello, I'm Brian, a developer on
the Google Drive Realtime API.
Everyone loves memes,
especially when they've
got pictures of
cute cats in them,
but not everyone's an
expert on coming up
with great meme ideas.
Maybe you know the
perfect background image
to use for a meme, but you
need a little bit of help
coming up with the
perfect caption text.
Why don't we build a
collaborative meme editor app
so that you and your
friends can meme together?
Now, what would a
collaborative meme editor app
actually look like?
It would look a
little bit like this.
You'd have a box where you can
select the image that you want
to use for the
background, and then we'd
have text boxes where you
could enter the top, middle,
and bottom caption text.
And because this is a
collaborative meme editor app,
we want to have character by
character collaboration just
like Google Docs.
And what that means is, when
one user types or deletes
or edits one of
these text boxes,
we want to see what they're
doing in real time, character
by character.
So how do we actually build
this collaborative meme app
the old-fashioned way?
Well, the first thing we have
to do is design our server.
And because we
have this character
by character
collaboration, this server
needs to deal with
a lot of load.
Every time someone
types on their keyboard,
we're going to get
a request, and that
means a ton of traffic to our
database and a ton of requests
to our application server.
Once we've got the
server figured out,
we need to figure out how
to deal with collaboration,
and that means
resolving conflicts.
If one user inserts text and
another user deletes text,
we need to resolve that in
a way that causes everyone
to end up with the same result.
And then of course we have to
deal with all of the minutiae.
We have to deal with
authentication and access
control, and we have to
deal with the network code
and write a bunch of glue
code to bring all this stuff
together.
Once we're done
with all of that,
then we can get
on to the fun part
where we build a
great user experience
and build a great meme app.
But we're not
really here to talk
about how to do
this the hard way.
We're here to talk about how you
do this with the Drive Realtime
API, which looks a
little more like this.
All that hard stuff?
We just replaced it
with the Realtime API.
And all you have to do is
build a great meme application,
build your user
interface, and figure out
how to make your app wonderful.
But how easy is this really?
Well, as it turns out, with
the Drive Realtime API,
building a collaborative
app is really, really easy.
It's so easy that you can build
a collaborative meme editing
app with less work
than it would take
to build a traditional
non-collaborative app.
And that's because you
don't need server-side code.
You don't need to deal with
any of the persistent storage
or authentication or
anything like that.
You just build client side
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
and focus on making
your experience great.
So let's go step by step
through how we would actually
build this meme app
using the Realtime API.
The first thing we
need to do is we
need to include a little
bit of boilerplate
to load the Realtime API.
We then need to
read and write data
from what we like to call
a Realtime data model.
And then we have to handle
changes from other users
because this is a
collaborative app.
So let's go through a little
bit of this boilerplate,
and I promise that
this is painless.
The first thing
we need to include
is the standard Google
API loader script.
Now this is the same script
you'd use if you wanted to load
the Google+ button, or
the Google Drive API,
or really any other Google API.
And this is just something
you copy and paste.
Now the next thing
we do is actually
called the JavaScript
function to load the APIs.
This is called gapi.load.
We provide a list of the
Google APIs that we want.
In our case, we want
the Realtime API,
but we also might want something
like our authentication code,
or we might want the sharing
dialogue or the Drive API
or something like that.
We can provide as
many APIs as we need.
Once all of that's
loaded, we get a callback,
which we're just going
to use to wire up our UI.
And that's it for boilerplate.
Now we can get on to the
really cool part, which
is where we actually
read and save data
from the Realtime data model.
Now what is a
Realtime data model?
I've been talking about this.
Well it's kind of a fancy
term, but a Realtime data model
is just a collection
of data structures
just like an
in-memory data model.
And the kind of cool part
about a Realtime data model
is that Google handles
all of the collaboration
and all of the
storage work for you.
So you just read and write
from this Realtime data model,
just like it were in-memory,
and you write a user interface
on top of it and then all
the rest is handled for you.
So let's go through
a couple of examples
of how this Realtime
data model's built.
We're going to build it
using a variety of objects,
but in our case we're going
to use collaborative maps
and collaborative strings.
Now a collaborative map is just
like a JavaScript associative
array, except we
automatically merge changes
on a key by key basis
to handle collaboration.
And a collaborative string is
just like a JavaScript string,
except that we do character by
character diffing to figure out
the results of that
everyone gets the same text.
So let's actually start
building up our data model.
So at the root we're going to
have a collaborative map which
we've creatively called root.
And in fact, every
Realtime data model
has a collaborative
map at its root.
This is something that we
create for you automatically
as a sort of convenience.
And this is where you
can store all the data
that you need for
your application.
In our case we need three
different strings, the top,
middle, and bottom text.
And we're going to use
collaborative strings for this
because we want that character
by character collaboration.
If we didn't want the character
by character collaboration,
which is the case
for the image URL,
we can just use a plain
JavaScript string here.
And we'd just put that
in a collaborative map
like you were a
local data structure.
So let's look at actually
reading and writing
from this data model.
So to read, let's say we want
to get the image URL out.
We just call the get function
on the collaborative map,
just like it's an in-memory map.
And we get back our image
URL, our little picture
of the cute cat.
If we wanted to update that, say
to replace it with a cuter cat,
all we have to do is call set.
Now, this looks fairly
simple because it is simple.
This works just like a
regular old JavaScript object,
but under the covers
what we're doing
is serializing this,
sending it to the server,
handling collaboration,
and handling persistence.
All of this is done
for you automatically.
But there's one
thing that you need
to do that's a little bit
different from building
a non-collaborative
app and that's
that you need to handle
events from other users,
not just the local user.
So in the Realtime API,
we provide event listeners
on collaborative objects
just like dom elements.
But you could add listeners
to collaborative strings,
and you could add listeners
to the HTML input elements,
and wire all this up
together with some glue code.
But if you don't want
to do that to connect
the strings to
the text boxes, we
provide this clever utility
called the string binder.
And what a string binder
does is it automatically
wires up all the events for you
between a collaborative string
and an input element.
So all we do is call
bindString and provide
the collaborative string
and the input element,
and we wire up all the events
and all the collaboration
works automatically.
But there's one thing we need
to do in addition to making
the text boxes
work, and that's we
need to make the little
preview image update.
And to make the
preview image update,
we want it to update when
anything in the data model
changes.
And to do that we're
going to use something
called an object
change event listener.
And an object change
listener is just
a listener that fires
any time an object
or any of its children change.
And in our case, we're
going to add it to the root.
And by adding it to the
root, what we're doing is
we're making a listener
that fires anytime
anything in the
data model changes.
Now all we have to do is update
our little preview image.
And that's it.
We've built a collaborative
meme editor app.
So if you're ready to
get started writing code,
we have a great quick start
guide on our developer web page
where you can go through,
step by step, the actual code
that it takes to make
a little demo app.
And if you're interested
a little bit more
about the technical detail of
how the Realtime API works,
we have a great presentation
from Google I/O last year,
in which we go through all the
conflict resolution and undo
and things like that, in
great technical detail.
Thank you very much.